dear Kumar guaranteeing okay thank you
for coming so I'm going to talk about
the work done by Rahul Singh and he's
somebody in this bed yeah I don't
exactly know where right now so the so
about a year and a half ago the FCC
released about ten point eight five
gigahertz of spectrum in the millimeter
wave and three point eight five
gigahertz licensed seven gigahertz
unlicensed this is not megahertz this is
gigahertz and actually the fact that the
FCC released unlicensed the way I
interpreted is that it's a very liberal
move by the FCC you can think of it this
way you know
the spectrum has traditionally been
allocated by command and control but in
the case of Wi-Fi what happened is they
were talking about the 2.4 gigahertz
band which is the same frequency as the
microwave oven so that's called a
junkman
so FCC said guys do what you want and
that's where the revolution happened so
the in fact the that 2.4 gigahertz band
is more utilized than anything else so I
like to think of it as a FCC learning
that you can create a lot of innovation
and the economic activity through
innovative users in an unlicensed manner
okay and in fact they're proposing to
release another 18 gigahertz later
though I don't know what will happen in
the audit pyre error okay so it could be
that we may be coming to some kind of an
Information Age where there's a lot of
information flowing around us but there
are challenges this is in the millimeter
wave and these transmissions are
directional okay so they're not
omnidirectional they're kind of focused
there is absorption okay and the
question is the particular question I'm
going to look at is how can we support
low latency appliqu
Asians in this technology and you can
think of application any interactive
application may be augmented reality or
okay so the problem I'm going to
consider is multi-hop networks so we
have flows so this is a green flow from
one origin to destination there's a blue
flow multipath routing is possible and
there's red flow and so on and we'll
suppose there are capital F flows and
each flow has a hard end-to-end deadline
okay so the little F flow has an
end-to-end deadline tau F what I mean by
a hard end-to-end deadline is that I'll
only give credit for packets which are
received within that deadline so I'm
looking at the rate of delivery of
packets which meet the deadline okay and
so that I'm going to denote by RF and
this RF is like throughput but it is
throughput meeting hard deadlines so I
call it the timely throughput okay all
right and what about the nodes
themselves so we suppose that every node
has a average power constraint this is
traditional in information theory so on
an average a node can transmit at 1 watt
so occasionally two words occasional
half what but the average is one word
okay now I'm going to logical eyes this
average power constraint into a
concurrency constraint on the number of
packets so just suppose that each packet
transmission takes one watt okay so I'll
suppose that the average number of
packets at node I can have concurrently
under transmission is CI ok this is just
for convenience this is the long term
average and packet these links now this
is not omnidirectional transmission so
there is no collisions as such but links
are unreliable
so if node I sends a packet to node J
that may or may not get there and P IJ
is the probability of a successful
transmission okay and as I said there is
no interference
now we want to schedule this network
optimally and there are two challenges
okay
the first challenge is a challenge of
information and the second challenge is
one of competition so the information
challenges how to instantaneously obtain
all the information needed to schedule
the network optimally okay and the
second challenge is even if you could
get that information what is the
complexity of determining the optimal
scheduling policy okay so let me
illustrate what the information
challenges let us suppose that you have
a node here and let us suppose that it
has this dela might either needs to
transmit a packet a blue packet or a
green packet and let us suppose that if
it transmits a blue packet unfortunately
this downstream congestion so this
packet is going to get stuck in the
downstream traffic and probably won't
make it to its destination on time so
you don't get the credit for receiving
the packet on the other hand the green
packet there's no congestion so it's
better to transmit it so this shows that
knowing downstream congestion is
important in scheduling by similar token
knowing upstream congestion is also
important because maybe this particular
packet is already pretty delayed there's
another packet coming let us say so I
may I should wait for that and not use
my power on this packet which is already
delayed so the point is that in order to
schedule in network optimally you have
to know the complete state of the
network okay and but how but you need
this instantaneous knowledge of network
state but the whole point of this
communication is to scheduling the
network so that packets go from place a
to place B with low latency so we have a
chicken-and-egg problem okay and in fact
this is one of the fundamental reasons
why optimal scheduling of distributed
systems is difficult okay all right so
that's the information problem then
there's a computation problem let us say
that this information could be given to
you right away okay the question is how
do you compute the optimum policy so and
that the problem is that the network
state is pretty huge if there are V
vertices or nodes if the maximum delay
is Delta if there are capital F flows
then the state space
the network state space is huge there F
flows each flow could be could have up
to Delta packets so there are up to F
Delta packets in the network and then
each packet can belong to one of flows
and have a certain time to live etc so
you do the calculation and it's
exponential okay and now dynamic
programming with this exponential state
space is intractable you can reduce the
Namek programming to linear programming
by what are called state action
probabilities so you simultaneously look
at the probability of being in a certain
state and taking a certain action and
with those decision variables you can
formulate dynamic programming as a
linear programming problem okay
unfortunately that's a huge number so
even if you had the information
optimally scheduling this is difficult
so question how do we address this and
what I'm going to give you is a fully
decentralized and tractable and optimal
solution okay so so let RF as I
indicated earlier denote the throughput
of flag packets of flow F that meet this
hard end-to-end deadline constraint now
F and that's a timely throughput now
what I'm going to do is we have to look
at the feasible region right of delivery
rate vectors I'm going to examine one
point on the Pareto frontier so weight
flow apps through full throughput by
alpha F and look at the problem of
maximizing this weighted timely
throughput so there are capital F flows
RF is the throughput of flow F and this
is the weight okay and the problem I'm
going to examine is how to schedule the
network for maximizing this weighted
timely throughput okay and this slide is
the heart of the whole idea okay so
we're going to look at this as a Markov
decision process with constraint so we
know that Markov for Markov decision
problems there is an optimal in the
class of stationary randomized
strategies these are mappings from
States to probability distributions or
actions okay and this is what we want to
maximize I'm writing it as a long-term
average
for each flow f when you deliver a
packet you get alpha F dollars and this
is the event that the packet is
delivered that the packet is delivered
at time T within its deadline okay so
this is the reward that you collect and
there's a power constraint or a
concurrency constraint so this is the
average number of packets on the
transmission that no tie is bounded by
CI so this is a constraint Markov
decision process now we're going to
augment the constraint through a
Lagrange multiplier so we have a
Lagrange multiplier for each power
constraint we had joined that and we get
this Lagrangian now what we're going to
do is we're going to rearrange this
Lagrangian the way it is written is the
reward accrued at each time instant
depending on whether the packet was
delivered or power was consumed averaged
over time but we'll reorganize this
through via packets and it turns out
that you can be completely decoupled on
a packet by packet basis so the way I
look at it is I look for each flow I
look at the flows the packets of that
flow that you release before a certain
time and average over time okay now how
does a packet experience a reward or
cost if a packet reaches its destination
on time that is within its end-to-end
deadlines then it collects alpha F
dollars on the other hand every time it
requests transmission by no die it pays
lambda I dollars for the cost of energy
right so this is the reward or caused by
the packet and you can average over the
packets you get the same reward but now
this problem completely decoupled and we
have a decouple packet level decision
making so what is that so this is what a
packet is confronted with it gets a
reward if it reaches the destination on
time but has to pay money at all every
time it gets transmitted so the problem
looks as follows so let us say there's a
packet and this packet can completely
forget about the complete network state
it doesn't have to worry about the
network State it says to itself I am in
state I and I have tau days to live
so this is the state of the packet where
it is and how long before its deadline
expires and it is saying if I request to
be transmitted over this link to node J
then there's a probability pIJ that I
will make it and the question is should
I pay the toll
lambda that this node is asking and on
if it reaches the destination D in time
then it collects al $5 so this is what a
packet needs to optimize for itself so
it's a packet level decision making
problem completely oblivious to network
state okay and that's a very simple
dynamic programming problem first of all
the packet state is very small okay it
is not exponentially large it is just a
number of nodes and the maximum deadline
and this is dynamic programming if if it
reaches its destination with time to
spare time to live is non-negative then
it collects alpha dollars whereas if it
is in nor die with tau days to live it
can either not get transmitted or get
transmitted if it doesn't get
transmitted then it stays at the same
node one less state to live if it does
get transmitted it pays lambda I dollars
with probability pIJ it will go to node
J with one less day to live or if it
doesn't it'll stay where it is so it's a
simple dynamic programming problem that
could be solved offline and stored okay
and easy to solve because of the very
small state space okay now there are
some issues we'll get to that now so
this optimal solution completely
decouples okay so each packet makes its
own decision to be transmitted or not
depending only on its own state and it
does not depend on the state of other
nodes doesn't depend on the state of
other flows or even of other packets
within its flow okay now technicalities
now let us suppose lambda star is the is
a price vector and this is a optimal
optimal randomized policy for that price
vector and supposing at every node
either the power constraint is satisfied
with equality or the cost of power 0
okay that means either the constraint is
tight or it's loose in which case price
is 0 then complementary slackness
satisfied in this hood this is optimal
okay so technically there's no problem
this is a linear problem in a problem
but there is one small issue there is a
need for randomization okay whenever you
have a Markov decision problem with
average cost constraint there may be a
need to randomize just to use up all the
resource completely okay so the easy way
to so supposing this constraint is
satisfied with equality and just
consider the following example supposing
you transmit all the packets at the node
you use 10 watts and supposing you don't
transmit any packets at the node it's
zero watts and supposing both these
decisions are optimal for the given
price but supposing your power
constraint is 8 watts and in today to
randomize and transmit 80% of the
packets to use of the resource ok so
there is a randomization and there is
this additional decision on which flow
you should randomize and so on so there
are these these things which couple the
flows ok all right so we do need to
determine this optimal randomization
probabilities also the what about prices
well one way to one way to think about
prices is the straightforward way if the
price of energy is too low then too many
packets will ask to be transmitted and
so the average power constraint will be
exceeded on the other end if the price
is set too high then too few packets
will has to be transmitted and the power
won't be used up and that's not good
either so one possible solution is just
adjustment ok at all so you look at the
empirical running power and if you're
using too little power Jack it up and
and so on okay and you can think of this
as a sub gradient algorithm for the dual
ok but this is not the way we're going
to do it this is just to give you the
intuition so I'll give you one package
tractable packet that solves all these
issues we're not going to go buy a
prices will directly solve the primal so
how can we exploit all the structure to
determine the complete solution now the
point to note is that we do not need to
decide how we only need to decide how to
optimally schedule each packet we do not
need to decide how to schedule the
entire network so it's only packet level
decision-making
now there are this many types of packets
there are capital F flows each packet
can be in one of these states and have a
certain time to live so this is the
number of packet types okay and for each
packet type we need to make a decision
which link to send it on to or to which
node and at what power level and so the
number of state action pairs for a
packet level decision-making is small
okay and so we can write down a linear
program with these many variables and
that will be highly tractable and it'll
give the optimal solution so here's how
it looks so we combine all these flows
now into one big pot okay and here's a
linear program so this is the reward
function that you want to maximize and
these are the state action probabilities
so for flow F which is a node I and
which has s days to live if you try and
if you transmit it to the final
destination then it will make it'll
arrive there with this probability I'm
sorry it will get transmitted with this
probability and then it will get arrive
with this probability and then you
collect alpha F dollars and AF is by the
way the arrival rate of packets okay so
this is the accrued reward this is the
power constraint okay at each node you
can look at the average power and these
are the balance equations that is the
mass conservation of mass look a packets
in equals packet out and this is just
the fact that these are all
probabilities so this is a very
tractable linear program very low
complexity just this many variables and
this many constraints and in a dish it's
huge reduction from the exponential
complexity and in addition it's linear
program which is very easy to solve okay
so that's the complete solution both
informational e and computationally now
I've solved here the average cost
problem that is average power constraint
at each node now what supposing you have
peak power constraints so that means
that known this node I cannot ever
transmit at more than
and watts so it can never transmit more
than say 10 packets it's not average
concurrency it's maximum in that case
you can convert this into a kind of a
bandit problem okay through whittles
relaxation
so suppose node I can transmit only CI
packets concurrently then Whittle has
shown that when you have a multi-armed
bandit problem we know that if there's
just one arm there's this beautiful
getting's index but if there are
multiple arms there is no index but if
you relax the number of arms that you
can pull a take any given time to an
average constraint on the number of
pounds you can pull then under some
conditions it is indexable so that's
what we do we simply truncate we relax
this peak to an average we get an
optimal policy and then we truncate that
optimal policy so that it does no more
than ci pulls a down ok and this is
exactly similar to truncation of littles
policy and that is a asymptotically
optimal as the network is scaled up ok
everything in proportion so it is
quantifiably near optimum so we can we
can say something about how to do that
problem also and let me just make a few
comments about how this compares with
what has been done so there has been
there have been many important
developments in scheduling networks of
the past 25 years and the one important
very important development is a max
weight and back pressure policies this
goes back to the unrest as you listen to
me if limit ease and then later on buy a
whole bunch of other people ok and now
these back pressure policies are based
on a Lagrangian decomposition of the
fluid model ok and the fluid model is
appropriate for studying throughput in
fact that theorems which say that the
fluid model is stable then its
throughput stable and so on so the fluid
model is appropriate for studying
throughput but and it hasn't been very
successful at designing throughput
optimal policies but
delay depends on stochastic variations
it needs a stochastic model you need to
consider second moments and things like
that and this is like the difference
between the law of large numbers and the
central limit theorem okay so what we
are doing here is not a relaxation of
the fluid model but a relaxation of the
complete Markov decision process that
captures all the stochastic city in the
system and this is something Lagrange
multipliers are very different so for
the fluid model for back pressure the
Lagrange multipliers are the differences
in queue lengths the back pressure okay
but in our case the Lagrange multiplier
is the price of energy so quite quite
different now this theory can be used to
explicitly solve examples just to give
you an illustration supposing you have a
so you can put in text books again so
supposing you have a read flow this way
a blue flow this way and these are the
reliabilities of the links and these are
the waiting's I should have called them
alpha then you can calculate the optimal
prices just hand calculation and you can
determine the optimal solution that is
at node one you should transmit with
probability 0.5 if the time till
deadline is 3 else drop at flow for flow
one flow flow to at node 3 you should
transmit with this probability and so on
so explicit optimal solution you can
also do numerical comparisons which I
mean it's optimal so it does better ok
so so I've addressed here the problem
without contention we can do we can say
some things for contention not as
complete and as thorough as this but
there are some things we can say and
there are lots of other issues that he
can examine including things like coding
and so on so forth
[Applause]
[Music]
even the optimal option for what what's
what do you want to maximize minimize
mean delay minimize mean delay may not
be optimal see it may not be optimal to
regulate all packets with the same delay
in order to reduce mean you may in that
case you may want to take advantage of
network conditions or and so on okay
yeah so then it becomes like a max-flow
min-cut thing because if I give you the
concurrency constraint that's like a cut
capacity and so it may reduce to a
deterministic problem so just think of
it as one it's like fluid model with the
fluid pipes bounds and so then it's just
determine a super linear Nina problem
it's saying yeah
yes because the thing is that I can have
different deadlines for different flows
in this formulation so you can just
think of that as infinity so that's not
a problem
yeah yes yes so you can have here you
can have some flows which have no delays
some hopefully there's different delays
and still Optima
yes in principle it would yes in
principle it would but I suspect that
you can get pretty close to near optimal
just because after some number of
Bernoulli trials it's not worth it yeah
[Applause]